welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and black panther wakanda forever's
trailer leaves us with a mystery of who
is in this new vibranium suit let's hope
the memes are wrong and it's not ryan
gosling i mean nothing against our
future ken doll but you know it's just
our hearts are broken enough one major
overlooked detail hidden in the suit's
design actually opens up a whole new
possibility i actually found five new
things now that this imax trailer is
here with parts of it and wider aspect
ratio and all of it in sharper 4k detail
so let's break down all the new stuff of
course the trailer ends with the reveal
of this mystery figure in the suit and
kendrick lamar's alright cutting to
black on and when i wake up the theory i
post in the trailer breakdown which you
should watch if you haven't already is
that this could be a clue pointing to
this being a resurrected character like
killmonger who was buried at sea at the
end of the 2018 film and might therefore
tie in with the ocean dwellers who are
opposed to the wakandas in this film we
actually just learned that the name of
their home is not atlantis in this movie
but tlalocan inspired by the paradise
from aztec mythology neymar and its
people draw from both mayan and aztec
influences similar to how for the 2018
film ryan coogler's team drew influences
from across the african continent to
create the fictional wakanda mythology
actually one detail that we didn't
mention from namor's birth shot this
baby has wings on his feet the same that
namor has in the comics but getting back
to that detail of who is in the suit in
the trailer angela bassett as queen
ramonda declares i am queen to the most
powerful nation in the world and my
entire family is gone have i not given
everything and since she says my entire
family that tells us shuri is either
missing or presumed dead which i
interpret as a strong indicator that
shuri might go into the ancestral plane
in search of backup and assuming that
t'challa's death of natural causes we
think might lead his panther spirit to
be unable or unwilling to return to this
realm and force shuri to seek her more
eager cousin killmonger's assistance but
as dr strange saw when he resurrected
the dead this might be a mistake that
the living pay a brutal cost for as
killmonger escalates this conflict with
a scorched earth strategy or rather we
should say a flooded earth but a huge
detail is hidden in this mystery suit's
design we've been so focused on the
shape of this silhouette and compare it
to the various actors physiques but on
the gauntlet there is an open mouth of a
panther its fangs shutting into the
forearm these may remind you of the
panther head gauntlets that shuri wields
in the final battle of the 2018 film
which fire concussive blasts that
retracted killmonger's vibranium so the
very least this design detail suggests
that shuri designed this suit which
doesn't make sense she is the designer
behind all the sleek tech that we see
from the more subtler suit that t'challa
chose to the more pronounced golden suit
that killmonger chose really this final
trailer shot has invited us to consider
all possibilities from killmonger to
shuri herself to the theory that this
could be ramonda either a flashback to a
past conflict with namor's people
perhaps the origin of the bad blood
between the kingdoms or hell maybe even
the present day i mean based off of this
trailer angela bassett has some fighting
spirit but another detail we should
point out is the object beside raimondo
on the armrest of the throne earlier in
the trailer which i speculate it could
be made of vibranium this now looks like
it is in the shape of a conch shell i
think it'd be sick to have a conch shell
made of iranium to represent these two
kingdoms being the only sources of
vibranium on the planet this could have
been sent to wakanda as a warning or a
ransom note or perhaps a totem
representing a past truce between the
kingdoms maybe a means of communication
between the kingdoms like the red phone
in the oval office with the direct line
to the kremlin don't tell me a conch
shell can't be a telephone when you put
them to your ear you hear the ocean and
it's because neymar wants to talk when
you re-watch this trailer it is just
impossible to ignore the signs that
nakia might be playing a bigger role
than it seems lupita nyong'o was the
first member of the cast introduced by
director ryan googler at comic-con after
he reflected back on bean hall h in 2017
to introduce the first black panther he
talked about how the late chadwick
boseman was positioned directly to his
left and now chadwick opened his hand to
place it on his shoulder and this
trailer ends with a new black panther
figure opening their hand and now on
that hall h panel who was to the left of
brian coogler lupita nyong'o and the
trailer opens with of all characters
nakia who only appears once more right
around the midpoint and then the trailer
bookends with a mystery figure i know it
seems like i'm obsessing too much about
the editing of this trailer but i'm only
doing so because the disney editor who
actually cut this andrew hegley guested
on batman beyond with kevin smith and
mark bernardin and kevin smith my hero
blew my freaking mind by shouting us out
i think they do some pretty good deep
dive video work man a guy eric voss very
entertaining plug plug for the new rock
stars holy [ __ ] thank you my man
obviously i'm a huge fan of everything
you do and for everyone watching i
highly recommend you watch their full
episode because it's just super
insightful and entertaining especially
because this trailer editor specifically
went into his approach with cutting
trailers to music and he talked about
how the thames cover of no woman no cry
and kendrick lamar's all right form a
dialogue and how those opening and
closing statements were totally
intentional where is music in it for you
is that the first thought or later on
it is the beginning and end it is
everything now higley has cut the
initial teaser trailers for chongqi for
eternals for star wars andor and the
mandalorian and he said he thinks of
these as dreams i like i like to think
of uh uh trailers as
the especially teaser trailers which are
more mood building the if you watched a
movie and then you fell asleep and you
had a dream about it the trailer is the
dream you had
and uh i feel like that captures like
and again it all starts in this
particular case it starts with ryan and
lulu figuring out that saw no woman to
cry so if you see a connection between
this trailer opening with nakia and then
fading black on nikia and then all this
imagery in between being edited as a
dream and then ending with a mystery
figure cutting to black on the words and
when i wake up yeah there might be
something there now this interpretive
poetry analysis isn't enough for you the
visual evidence does support this
interpretation folks i pointed out that
shot of the wakanda necropolis that
ramonda and shuri are approaching in the
funeral march a march by the way that if
you look closely at that overhead shot
shuri is carrying t'challa's black
panther helmet there i know i know just
more and more reasons to cry here but
that gate shows bashenga with bost but
then to the right there is a female
companion with another feline that i
think might be segment the other feline
deity that t'challa mentioned in civil
war in my culture
dead
it's not the end
it's marve
stepping off point
you reach out with both hands and bust
and sekhmet
they lead you into the green belt where
you can run forever now think about it
would this shrine include a statue of
bashenga's mother or sister or his
spouse if it's his spouse that would set
up nakia to be the heir to the mantle so
i'll leave it to you to decide the
silhouette of this mystery figure
honestly it feels pretty weird to talk
about how good of shape all these actors
are in i mean you could say that the
curves might look more masculine from
this angle but its arms might look
thinner than what we remember michael b
jordan looking like in the 2018 film you
could say that the arms roughly match
the width of nakia's arms from the
opening shot though lupe duniago is
wearing a costume there so it's kind of
hard to tell i mean these suits are
often worn by stunt actors or just all
of it vfx anyway to me the more
important clue is how the suit assembles
shuri designed them to be contained
within a necklace or some other article
of jewelry that the wearer can walk
around in by the way i don't i don't
know how t'challa or tony stark would
walk around with their entire suits
contained within a small apparatus i
mean those necklaces would be heavy as
[ __ ] but whatever it's a movie remember
t'challa's suit had silver trimming and
was encased within a silver colored
vibranium necklace so if this suit has
gold trimming we probably should look
for someone wearing gold jewelry and yes
lots of characters wear golden jewelry
ramonda neymour but there is this one
shot showing shuri sobbing as she is
held by another female figure who wears
a golden bracelet on her right hand
again the right-handed mystery figure is
what the trailer cuts to black on we do
see shuri earlier in the trailer doing
the handshake with ribri williams
wearing the same golden bracelet i think
she designed this bracelet wore it
initially and then handed it off to
someone else and in this shot of her
crying i'm pretty sure that is the arm
of nakia and in the opening shot of this
trailer on the beach you can barely make
out a faint glimmer of gold reflecting
off of nakia's wrist i don't know nakia
being in the suit here does not rule out
the possibility of killmonger still
getting resurrected from the ancestral
plane in this movie both could still be
possible in fact we might just see
several characters in black panther's
suits in this movie let me know who you
think this is based on this new evidence
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you